no one has shown more contempt for other
nations and for the well-being of their
own people than the depraved regime in
North Korea it is responsible for the
starvation deaths of millions of North
Koreans and for the imprisonment torture
killing and oppression of countless more
we were all witness to the regime's
deadly abuse when an innocent American
college student otto warmbier was
returned to America only to die a few
days later we saw in the assassination
of the dictators brother using banned
nerve agents in an international airport
we know it kidnapped a sweet 13 year old
Japanese girl from a beach in her own
country to enslave her as a language
tutor for North Korea's spies if this is
not twisted enough now North Korea's
reckless pursuit of nuclear weapons and
ballistic missiles threatens the entire
world with unthinkable loss of human
life it is an outrage that some nations
would not only trade with such a regime
but would armed supply and financially
support a country that imperils the
world with nuclear conflict no nation on
earth has an interest in seeing this
band of criminals armed itself with
nuclear weapons and missiles the United
States has great strength and patience
but if it is forced to defend itself or
its allies we will have no choice but to
totally destroy North Korea Rocketman is
on a suicide mission for himself and for
his regime the United States is ready
willing and able but hopefully this will
not be necessary that's what the United
Nation
ian's is all about that's what the
United Nations is for let's see how they
do